is just
I'm Blown Away how many of the people
are here today
um
jury that was beautiful
really
um
I'm going to read something that
my granddaughter wrote
for all of you
and this says it all
the old soul
I have no idea how to put my mother into
words
truth is there are too many
Lisa Marie Presley was an icon a role
model a superhero to many people all
over the world
but mama was my icon
my role model My Superhero
in much more ways than one
even now I can't get across everything
there is to be understood or known about
her
but as she always said
I'll do my best
the old soul this is a poem
the old soul
in 1968 she entered our world born tired
fragile yet strong
she was delicate but was filled with
life
she always knew she wouldn't be here too
long
childhood passes by with a glimpse of
her green eye
she then grew a family of her own
then came her second child
leaving her with suspicion could this be
the angel that takes me home
time of course flew by it was time for a
tragedy
she knew it was close to the end
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was a doing of her death
now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
foreign
she knew that I loved her
I fear I'll never touch her but the old
soul is always with me
she doesn't drift above
that says it all
and thank you all for being here and
never own your brother
thank you for being here
and the family of course and all of you
our heart is broken Lisa we all love you
thank you